con una ceremonia tradicional que se ha
realizado por siglos en este país pero
adaptada a nuestros tiempos a la
modernidad porque fue transmitida paso a
paso por la televisión que tuvo millones
de espectadores alrededor del mundo y
que por primera vez tuvo una mujer
presidiendo la peni mordán que es la
jefe en la cámara de los comunes del
gobierno un cargo político fue la
primera mujer entonces en liderar en
oficializar que carlos tercero se
convirtió en el nuevo rey y grassi de
esta manera entonces ha comenzado podría
decirse de manera oficial el reinado de
carlos la ceremonia de ascensión al
trono todavía no se ha realizado no hay
fecha pero ésta tarda un tiempo podría
ser incluso en un año
carlos juró lealtad a la corona renovó
los votos de su madre la reina isabel y
dijo que su vida va a estar dedicada al
servicio y a la monarquía una de sus
primeras decisiones como monarca fue
decidir que el día del funeral de la
reina isabel segunda será un día festivo
en este país luego el rey carlos en el
palacio de buckingham muy cerca desde
donde nos encontramos se reunió con los
líderes políticos del país primero con
la primera ministra liz tras quien lleva
apenas cuatro días en su cargo y también
con el gabinete recién designado además
se reunió con los líderes de los
partidos de la oposición el rey tuvo
audiencias privadas también con los
líderes espirituales del país con el
decano de westminster y también con el
representante con el arzobispo de la
iglesia anglicana el arzobispo de
canterbury el rey carlos también se
convirtió en el jefe de la iglesia
anglicana y de la iglesia escocesa hoy
también en la tarde como ustedes pueden
ver a mis espaldas en el parlament o en
la cámara de los comunes un grupo
pequeño de diputados presentó su
juramento al rey carlos entre ellas el
speaker de la cámara de los comunes el
presidente y la primera ministra liz
tras el restante de los 650 diputados
que hacen parte de la cámara de los
comunes y de los lores
en este juramento al rey luego de que la
cámara del parlamento retomé labores
después de que pase este luto nacional y
el parlamento sigue rindiendo tributo a
la figura a la imagen y al servicio de
isabel segunda quien estuvo 70 años y
siete meses en el trono británico